right well thanks for making it out
tonight so my name isn't Bob Paulson I'm
one of the founders at Huck industries
and I look after the tech team there
just a little bit of background about me
I've had quite a varied career I studied
science I've been a management
consultant I've worked as an artist a
lecturer but for about the last 15 years
I've been working as a technologist
mostly in mobile and then more recently
in data analytics so I'd love to share
the things that we've learned so we've
had a journey about four or five years
long and we've definitely made a bunch
of mistakes in that and learned a lot of
lessons hopefully some of you can take
some of those away this evening so Huck
Industries Huck industries was founded
in 2014 we're a geolocation company we
use mobile data to provide insights and
provide data and analytics into a
variety of verticals so those include
financial services both quantitative and
fundamental funds property consultancy
and planning also out of home it's
basically like billboard advertising
essentially any application where you
want to be able to understand the macro
behavior of people at large scale and
how they move in the real world so oh
yeah so what I'm going to talk about
kind of is a brief overview of some of
the things that we've learned but by no
means covers all the details if you'd
like to know more and please feel free
to grab me afterwards and yeah so that's
about it
so for now I just want to rewind a few
years back to about 2015
we'd recently raised our first seed
round and were basically setting out to
build our first product so at this point
our focus was very much around providing
insights to application developers that
provided them ways of understanding the
context in which their users were using
those applications so essentially it
would enable those guys to build
experiences that change depending on
where the users were so if the user is
on their way to work the experience
they've got might be different to that
if they were say in retail environment
so yeah at this point all we had to do
was get some clients and build the
product so the product was web-based
dashboard in case anyone's ever built
web-based dashboard I don't recommend it
but feel free to give it a crack so yeah
and we built with deciding that we built
that ourselves in order to surface the
analytics that we were creating so have
this highly defined vision of what it
was going to be and very short time
scale in which to do it
we had a new newfound group of investors
and they were keen to see results so
yeah we basically went full steam ahead
on development and about two months
later had a product that was almost live
not quite and so it was a fairly
rigorous hard-nosed process of accessing
features and basically forcing it to go
live and that enabled us finally to
launch in the early part of 2016
and it was really only at that point
that we could reflect on what we've made
so far and and basically understand it
and that's why I would strongly
recommend anyone who does this sort of
thing to just seriously push towards
going live as fast as possible they say
that if you want embarrassed by your
first product released then
you waited too long so I can certainly
say that we didn't wait too long so I'm
just going to now show you first so
brief caveat on this first architecture
it's so basically I'm going to tell the
story of our development principally
through three primary architectures that
we've developed so it's almost one a
year not quite one a year but
essentially it kind of fine it provides
a way of kind of tracking our progress
through our journey this point it's
pretty hard to think really modularly
when you've got a very very tight time
scale and also that you have in a way
thought about your product as only one
thing it was only ever design to do one
thing it had one singular purpose that
was the vision that we had and so we
didn't really start building it in a way
that was adaptable but so data would
come in to engine X and that would be
passed into our primary processing
application which would do a bunch of
third party lookups and then dump that
data into database so all of this is
happening synchronously because at this
point we want to return a response to
the client we then have a secondary
analytics application you could call it
essentially this is building insights
rolling at building roll-ups from the
data and exposing those to the client
via dashboards so this was great it
worked and yeah it was live it worked
clients were liking it but what we
realized at this point was there was in
fact a much larger business opportunity
here and that probably we weren't going
to yeah
you know just providing these insights
to application developers yeah might not
be the only long-term thing we could do
in fact it's quite hard for those guys
to take action upon those and yeah it
was
anyway other things to think about but
that we could aggregate this data and
anima is in aggregate this data and then
make that available to other people who
would be interested in these aggregated
analytics so at this point we embarked
upon a data recruitment drive because
essentially we were going to need a lot
more publisher data in order to perform
this and naturally looking after the
engineering the question I was asking
was well what happens if we end up with
a lot more data than we can process and
the answer was well that would be a nice
problem to have I don't know if anyone's
ever heard anyone say this but if you do
you should meet it with a mixture of
emotions one of those should be fear so
yeah basically a couple of weeks later
don't worry I'm not gonna do any live
coding but a couple of days later this
is like what the server is looking like
that's the extent of the live coding so
we did what any right-thinking technical
team does in this situation and that is
scale vertically of course so basically
by bigger server and next week by big
server redeployed the same code again on
a bigger server after at this point we
were growing our data volume at a rate
of about 100% week on week so pretty
much within about six weeks we were on
the largest box that you could get at
OVH and it was obvious that there were
some more fundamental things that we
need I wasn't expecting to get so many
laughs so yeah I mean it's a tried and
tested approach so what we realized of
course is that we really need to revisit
the way the architecture itself was
organized so if we go back to our
diagram the main problem we had is we
have all the a lot of elements here
which are extremely closely coupled and
yeah we have synchronous tasks passing
data both into the primary application
looking up external data sources tying
to the database we had like nginx timing
out over 20 seconds to reply dead locks
on the database basically was but
fortunately one of the things that had
come out of our shifting focus which was
to not reply to the data immediately was
that some of our requirements had
shifted and so one of those requirements
is we didn't need to return any data in
the response that came in to us in nginx
so we could basically just create a
small application which just would then
dump that data onto a queue so we chose
kathcart there's obviously lots of other
options so now in this scenario like
that top at the top left application is
tiny little application it literally all
it did was consume the data dump on
queue and return 200 immediately so
immediately this had a very positive
effect we could then consume the data
from that queue whatever the speed that
we liked and immediately the whole
system was significantly happier
basically additional benefit is like the
queue then was smoothing out bumps in
the data so we would have traffic the
varies across the day naturally we would
have like spikes at certain points and
this would then enable us to like smooth
out those spikes so it was at least
stable we're getting 200 responses on
all of our requests stuff was not timing
out database was happier and so I think
is interesting to reflect certain points
on things that happen that have a long
term impact upon your architectural
decisions and one of the things that we
learned here was
that of all of the things that are
broken so we had inconsistent databases
with periods of data and there were
maybe we were like you could say
faithful and bits which were unfaithful
various logs of various places which
were broken one thing that was
consistent throughout all of this was
the nginx logs so those then became kind
of our single source of truth you could
think of it like that we had unbroken
history of those so so yeah so yeah we
had then at least now stable system if
not capable of reprocessing all of our
data history at least reprocessing some
and yet we were it was working so I'm
just gonna this a bit of an interlude I
didn't really know quite where to drop
this in because it's not specific to any
particular piece of architecture or any
particular develop development that we
made we used it across time basically
from about this time in our development
and yet it's one it's something that
we've just found to be like SuperDuper
useful basically in a variety of
applications so initially we used it as
a technique to support us when we were
migrating individual pieces of it
architecture so what it would know what
you to do would be to say here data
coming again to nginx being forwarded on
to a particular port and have our
primary application listening on that
port what you can do is use a tool such
as don't replay go replay spin one of
our favorites over time to mirror the
traffic that's coming into that port so
you can then spin up alternative
application and test basically that
everything is working fine before me you
know before deploying that this you know
your dev application into the live
environment the cool thing about it is
you can just keep doing this as many
times as you like so you can have
potentially multiple application
all running off the same primary data
wheel in fact to use this for a lot of
different purposes load testing is
particularly powerful so instead of
forwarding all of the traffic to
different applications you can then four
you can duplicate it as many times as
you like and forward it all back to the
same application so we found simulating
live data kind of tricky using more
conventional load balanced load testing
tools often data that's generated by
them is kind of formulaic and we prefer
to yeah test basically using data as it
would be from though yeah as our live
stuff is and we still in fact use this
technique to create fully redundant
backups of of our live data so yet
basically essentially duplicating it
nginx now also has this function built
directly into it so it's called the
mirror directive it's really awesome
so we now actually use go replay less
and this is what we often use for
creating or redundant backups and what
is cool about both of these ways of
doing out so there's loads of others
which we haven't discovered is that
they're really really resilient so we've
had servers that are full now sync with
AWS for example and can't have laid
their data to s3 fill up completely with
logs so you virtually can't connect to
them and these services will continue
running so even though in on more than
one occasion these have saved us in
terms of helping us to maintain full
historical data integrity so I strongly
recommend trying out if you have any
need to process real-time web traffic
yeah or requests so anyway back to kind
of like the new requirements that we had
on our system so basically as we'd
shifted
there were some ways that we could
probably capitalize on kind of our new
client base or our new orientation and
there were also additional challenges so
[Music]
so the first of those is that we didn't
any longer need to be able to process
the data in real time and this is a
really big thing for us basically
because it meant that we could then
likes batch the data we could store it
we didn't have to design a system any
longer where all of the elements are
like super tightly connected we can have
a much more decoupled structure so it
took us a while to really think you know
and kind of talking to clients to
discover that they didn't actually want
this because I think it's easy to assume
that ok people want stuff like
immediately and in fact almost all of
the people that we sell our insights to
don't actually want it immediately 48
hours after real time is completely fine
so yeah this enables us to process the
data in batches enables this that are
then to run cleanup processes after that
and deliver it to client facing
locations and check its integrity or
before those guys want to be able to
pick it up secondly though we wanted to
be able to meet scale requirements to
the future we're like now firmly in a
growth phase and it was no longer enough
to merely be able to be comfortably
processing data of current level but we
needed to really be able to anticipate
growth as time went on and be confident
that the system is not going to yeah
kind of thought a bit and thirdly we
needed to be able to reprocess our
historical data so often we want to be
able to make ongoing changes to the code
base and for many of our clients they're
building models they're training models
against the data itself and they want
the full history to be delivered in one
assistant state it's not enough to oh
well it's not acceptable really to just
be like pushing changes to the code base
so that this yeah the ongoing stream is
changing as time goes on we want to be
able to deliver full history all
processed in one single way and so yeah
basically we had B these are kind of
like the things we need to go to do so
we were like obviously obviously but
maybe wanted to move to a kind of more
service infrastructure so we're a tiny
little team basically there's six people
and company and deploying your own
infrastructure can be really onerous
it's not only the deployment you've got
to monitor it check everything's okay
and all of those sorts of things so yeah
we were after solutions that would scale
smoothly where we didn't have to do so
much that and so we started using AWS
lambda basically for those who you
haven't used it or don't know what it is
AWS lambda is compute service provided
by AWS essentially you can run any code
base on it it will be invoked and it
will be essentially well you can run any
code base that you don't need to persist
for more than 15 minutes at a time so
it's invoked it stays up for 15 minutes
and during those 15 minutes you can do
whatever you want so you can communicate
with databases external data sources but
it will be destroyed 15 minutes later
and yeah so that's basically what it is
so so this is how now our architecture
would looked in its new iteration so
data comes onto the platform we're now
running engine X inside docker and put
this on a number of different nodes so
this this sits behind an AWS service
called route 53 which is a latency based
DNS service and then put these
containers onto a bunch of load balance
nodes so we can just spin up more of
those whenever we want to be able to
handle more traffic and that then
periodically just dumps the data into
AWS s3 now what's cool about lambda is
that you can set it to be triggered when
a new file arrives in s3 so we set ours
to be yeah so that then that lambda will
pick up the new file and then just
basically process it we were then we're
then connecting our persistent data on
RDS yes RDS which we're running Postgres
RDS and then when it's complete it's
pushing the output data to client facing
buckets and to now to also to Google
bigquery so this is actually kind of a
compressed diagram of how it actually
works there's actually a couple more
stages in this but essentially this
gives you conceptually their way it
works for the benefit so this this was
now super powerful and what's cool about
yeah this is like the more data you put
into s3 the more lambdas get invoked you
don't have to worry at any point about
provisioning more infrastructure just
essentially scales smoothly another cool
thing about this way of organizing is it
organizing it is that we could then have
like green-blue deployment so we can we
were basically completely mirror the
architecture and then have those running
entire two different V pcs and just
essentially this means that you have
like essentially like Devon live
environments which are running identical
architectures everything about them is
identical you can deploy to whichever
one isn't your current live and check
everything's fine before switching over
to it results in for us it was really
good because
it may means we can do fewer deployments
and resulted in a kind of like better
level of checking the integrity of new
developing new commits basically okay
I'm gonna speed up because I've been
gone five minutes I'd say some of the
benefits so yes so for the auto scaling
more data you put in the more lambdas
you get super simple and then also yeah
and your cost scales directly as a
result of how much compute you use
that's but there were lots of problems
basically not lots of problems but
somebody's one of them particularly for
us was the stability so in this scenario
what we would find would be that
essentially exists in a kind of locally
stable state if like we'd be running
fine under normal circumstances but it's
quite easy to throw it out of whack so
if the lambda failed for example it
would be retried we would set them to
retry to in and up with holes in the
data and that problem then of retry and
can often exacerbate the original
problem so if that's a database related
issue like connection count or database
load essentially the problem spirals out
of control
so yet wouldn't generally write itself
also there's an upper size on how much
of this you can use I think only one
thousand simultaneously simultaneous
invitations of lambda so yeah that's
kind of stuff that pushed us on to like
further things ideally we would like to
be able to have not just two pipelines
as many pipelines as we liked resilience
I've just mentioned and also the pace of
reprocessing if you think about
essentially at that rate of about a
thousand that would take us historically
maybe between one and two months to
reprocess of our full data history
that's a long time so so we chose to
move to beam and so beam is super
awesome base
it kind of brings distributed computing
to the masses I think it's essentially a
library that enables you it's language
agnostic enables you to write your code
in Python Java I think there's other
options and then you can run it on
whatever MapReduce runtime you want so
that supports spark and flink we've
chose Google dataflow which yes so this
is a brief distributed programming guide
in distributed processing you kind of
have to think about your data pretty
differently and this in this model then
kind of think about your data is a
stream and each step in the processing
as a transformation applied to that
stream so you can no longer really think
about having a single overarching
application state you have to think
about essentially or think about kind of
sending data to a method and getting a
response back you just think about like
transforming the data through a set of
processes so we chose Google dataflow as
mentioned before small team love fully
managed services insane amount of
potential power basically you can run a
thousand compute engine instances on any
job and each and even a general compute
engine instance can be up to 96 of these
CPUs so there's a ton of power you can
run 125 jobs concurrently that's even
without asking them to raise the
thresholds which I'm sure they would do
so yeah this was a no-brainer for us and
there were a bunch of hurdles that we so
we entered this project with it like a
lot of enthusiasm and super high hopes
that it was basically going to be this
like magic bullet for us but of course
at various points we just hit these kind
of what felt like brick walls but we
navigated them each successfully I'm not
going to go into depth of these about to
run out of time
but if you'd like to talk I did another
talk recently where I discuss each of
these in kind of a bit more
death and so finally this is how our
current our infrastructure works
currently so codes push to github and
then run on circle CI if the tests pass
we merged the branch into release and at
that point a Google Cloud Composer
templates pushed up with the new version
incremented and that cloud composer then
runs the pipeline on a schedule so we're
running this on a daily schedule and
then the data is outputted into Google
bigquery cool thing is that you can run
as many of these as you want so just
increment the version spin up a new
template have a new completely parallel
architecture turn them on and off as you
want so you could do per awesome so
thank you very much that's about it for
me
just a quick note we're not hiring but
which I know is a shock but I'm always
interested to meet people who are
interested interest you know anyone
smart people scientists engineers we
have time for a couple of questions they
have questions around that the
architecture I've found with lambdas the
runtime has some interesting
deficiencies so there's there's no
proper multi-processing so you can't use
pools your knees pipes it's compiled
without sequel lights so you're a monkey
patch it too gets greatly to work it's
there's the question coming so it's a
little bit interesting that ffmpeg mp4
codec started breaking just as soon as
they released elastic transcode what was
your other than the scaler the root
layer the ceiling on scaling what was
your sort of most interesting deficiency
of the of the runtime yeah I don't we
don't do anything SuperDuper exotic to
be honest so and you know we did try and
really work out what is it under the
hood like what I mean I think is
basically some kind of container yeah we
didn't encounter any problems with
package management or any particular
things but as I say it's like a lot of
our stuff is I would say fairly vanilla
we often not yeah we do use external
libraries and I mean what we would do is
we would like roll everything up into
the code that we would push up to AWS so
we weren't installing stuff after the
lambda was initialized we basically like
bundle up all our requirements and push
them up beforehand so yeah I don't if
that answers your question but didn't
have any super
Yeah right
I think that's what we worked out in the
end
there's a button I don't some of the
pain points mentioned on the first
architecture were around and like
consistency instability you'd built
everything around a lot of synchronous
functions that had a tendency to fail
and blow holes in your data and by the
time you'd built I think the second door
boasts the way to the third architecture
you sent it everything around s3 yes is
eventually consistent and you're
processing all your data with lambda
which is maybe if you're very lucky
eventually executes yes twice or many
times was that a consequence of shifting
requirements or did you repeat the
mistake a little bit question about
consistency yes I mean basically records
as they come most of those processes are
kind of like idempotent doesn't matter
which order they happen in basically so
the code is written so that if you were
to process records from yesterday today
and then process today's records to
Martin and it is it wouldn't make any
difference basically yes so yes as time
goes on the way in which the data that
we ingest interacts with the persisted
stores ultimately all shapes out so we
don't ascend chily need highly
consistent in beamland we you know you
can't basically use transactional
databases anyway in this way so we
essentially load all of the data into P
collection all of the data that would be
in a transactional database into P
collection at the beginning of the batch
process that throughout the stream and
then write it all back at the end but
yeah
the problems we were having in the first
iteration were really mostly about load
and just essentially asking Postgres to
do too much work all in one place rather
than necessarily anything specifically
associated with consistency your
question for the brief it's about would
he be in the pub afterwards I will be in
the pub afterwards so there's an option
to ask is about questions yeah now
during the break and then in the pub
afterwards let's give you a border
around the pose
you